now to India where figure show it is
backsliding in its fight against
malnutrition newly released world hunger
index now places India behind neighbors
including Bangladesh Sri Lanka and
Myanmar it's estimated that more than 3
million children in the country are
malnourished that's about half of them
severely DW's Manila chowder reports
not every day six-year-old bhushan comes
to this Education Center for
underprivileged Children my finger her
parents work as rock Pickers a big
reason they sent her here is the free
nutritious meal she gets
same is the case with many other
children
ages Asia the NGO which runs this Center
has for years been trying to ensure not
only good education but adequate
nutrition for children coming from
underserved communities
abna Edwin the project coordinator here
says that in every slum Community they
conduct a survey they find roughly 80
percent of children to be malnourished
many kids and many families struggle in
this area because of their financial
status too they're not able to provide
good nutrition to their kids and that
can lead to
underdevelopment and that can affect the
cognitive development you know
recent Global hunger index report has
thrown more light on this situation
the annual report which combines four
components under nourishment child
stunting child wasting and child
mortality has ranked India 107 out of
121 countries
and it has labeled the level of hunger
in the country as serious but the
government has not taken well to this
report
the Indian government had rejected the
global hunger index report calling it
erroneous biased and disconnected from
ground reality it also says the index
deliberately ignores the efforts made by
the government to ensure food security
for the population Deepa Sinha a
professor of Economics says this claim
does not hold any ground and that the
index uses official government data she
says the report should motivate the
government to review the measures they
have taken so far
there are a number of policies in India
addressing the issue of hunger and
malnutrition but there are severe
limitations to these programs one is
that not everybody is covered there are
major exclusions and secondly also that
in terms of the nutrition content of
what the government is Distributing
there are limitations Deepa says it's
time to pause and reflect on what more
needs to be done
the teachers at the center agree at
their end they try to maintain height
and weight records of all the children
and accordingly bring changes to the
menu to cover their nutritional needs
coming from severely deprived
backgrounds
these children have found Hope and
nourishment here
giving them a chance to build a better
future